Speaker 1: Also humiliating,
by the way. New interview
on the anniversary of 911, the 21st
anniversary of 911, which was over the weekend.
Republican Senate nominee in Georgia, Herschel
Walker, appeared on Fox News's program
with Maria BARTIROMO, and he tried to make a
statement about the 21st anniversary of 911.
And it was completely unintelligible and
confusing, very shaky. The entire interview
was very shaky. He is now winning in more polls.
Walker is now ahead of Warnock in Georgia. And
look at how he can't even make sense of anything.
Speaker 4: Well, you know, you got to pay tribute
to the 911 victims, you know, but also, you
saw America come together. You saw America
come together because this country
was you know, it was on a war with
a country that didn't believe in us and wrecked.
Speaker 1: What this country was on the war
against a country that didn't believe in us. And
then the country came together. Does he think that
the Iraq war was related to 911, even though
that's been widely debunked for decades?
Does he think that the war was with a different
country? It's not clear what he's talking about.
Speaker 4: Now we have leaders in Washington
like Joe Biden doing venomous speeches.
Right. That doesn't believe in America people.
Speaker 1: Right. So Walker continuing to
really struggle to make any sense. Walker at one
point raised the great Maya Angelou and tried to
use language that certainly
would make Maya Angelou
up in the heavens. Roll her eyes, I'm sure.
Speaker 4: For this country I'm fighting
for Georgia, because if we give up that
seat and I know Maya Angelou said it,
when you see when somebody tells you who they
are, believe they know right now, says Revere,
one not been in office. We are higher
taxes, we got higher gas prices. We've got
the economy has gone is terrible.
Speaker 1: Right. We have almost full
employment. We have gas prices seeing one of their
fastest declines in a long time. The gas price
increase had nothing to do with Warnock. That gas
price decrease has nothing to do with Warnock.
And then as far as taxes going up there, just
there has not been a tax reform where, quote,
taxes have gone up and they've been the
vague and overarching way that Herschel
Walker is talking about. Just none of it makes
sense. During the same interview, Walker saying
70% of drugs go through Atlanta, Georgia.
Speaker 3: Tell me about the issues and what
needs to be done regarding the border and crime.
Speaker 4: Well, one of the things that people
don't know, George, is not a border state, but 70%
of the drugs coming into this country go through
Atlanta, Georgia. And that's something
that my opponent don't want to address.
Speaker 1: Well, he's not addressing it because
there's no evidence that it's true. It's really
unclear what Walker means by 70% of drugs
coming into this country go through Atlanta.
I researched it under any of its possible
meanings. I was unable to verify that claim.
Does he mean that the 70% of drugs are coming
through the Atlanta airport, which is a major
airport? Does he mean that 70% of the drugs
are being driven through Atlanta, Georgia,
on the roads? By no possible definition
was able to verify that. And then lastly,
Walker, with I think that this is a transphobic
statement, but it's not even really clear.
Speaker 4: That's something that my opponent
don't want to address. You don't want to address
the border. Have you noticed that? It seems like
everyone on the left don't want to address the
problem in this economy, crime. They don't want to
address they don't address men and women's sports
they don't want to address. They're even talking
about railroad to talk about whether men can get
pregnant. That's not important right now.
Speaker 1: He really has a way with words,
but I don't know what the hell he's talking
about. And he is increasingly winning
winning his race. Can you believe that?
If we look at the latest polling data,
the last three polls have Walker ahead. The
last three polls have Walker ahead. This is
a guy who should have 0% support. But our
electorate and particularly the electorates
of states like Georgia to some degree,
particularly among Republicans in Georgia.
Horrifying. Weaponized. Propagandized individuals.
It's scary stuff. Extraordinarily scary stuff.